[Music]
cool hi thank you for having me up here
I've only got five minutes so hold up
the morning when I'm about five minutes
from being done all right okay it's a
good more money it's okay thank you so
I'm here to talk about how my colleague
Jordan over there and I made ML a little
more accessible to non developers I
think as far as I'm aware everyone in
the room has some sort of software
background we work for a software
consultancy and a client of ours came to
us and with a problem and they said that
they have electrical and mechanical
engineers who are their domain experts
and they're trawling through just you
know bajillions that's the technical
word rows of data finding patterns and
finding problematic labeling things
basically is a classification problem
and the these experts were spending way
too much time doing things that weren't
what they'd been hired to do writing
code sifting through jump
I'm just trying different throwing
different things at the wall to see what
stuck until they could find the right
rules that would surface these
problematic entries they came to us and
said they want us to make it easier for
them to use machine learning they think
they could encode a bunch of these rules
so we did and we are actively I don't
want to share a little bit of what about
what we learned one of the most
important things that we learned was to
learn their vocabulary and speak to them
in their language and then help teach
them how to bridge the worlds between
data science machine learning Python and
what they're used to like jumper Jupiter
notebooks in some cases what we ended up
doing was we ended up writing some code
that would wrap in Python that would
wrap popular libraries like scikit-learn
or tensorflow to make it more accessible
to them so a couple examples of that and
now I'm gonna see which one of those
that is alright so one of things we did
is we wrapped some of the api's for
likes like you learn for example this is
opinion to a data set that we built
you'll notice that there's a bunch of if
checks the purpose here is to find
common errors catch them early and often
and then output a more meaningful
message and
I apologize and I roll this up in the
last 10 minutes so I don't have the
errormsgs handy i de sanitize some of
this because it's built for the client
but the point I'm trying to make is the
error message is that you tend to see
when using scikit-learn returns are for
other libraries they aren't
interpretable by a non developer and
often you can go pretty far into the
process before the problem shows up we
caught a lot of these earlier wina
pending data for example the next thing
we tried to do let's see which one this
is yeah so the next thing we tried to do
is give them the ability to use multiple
burners at the same time and could then
compare the results so you can see here
that comparing learners is as easy as
just defining which ones you want we
just put them in an array we run them
all and then we use a confusion matrix
too to help us understand which ones are
working well and help us understand them
making that easy and there's
visualization aspect here that I had to
cut out again apologize for sanitizing
it but making it easy to apply multiple
learners so that you can see which ones
are doing well on your problem domain
and which ones aren't was critical to
our success and then the visualization
part was also very important to allowing
non developers to be able to interpret
the results non-sena stations to be able
to interpret the results intuitively ok
so another thing that we built for them
was the ability to automate feature
exploration I think Alissa touched on it
by the way your excellent presentation
thank you features are the things with
which machine learning will turn on and
will attempt to find the pattern in tune
to learn on so what we did is often in
these data sets the tables in the
database aren't what you need to find
the results I believe also described it
as something where the there aren't hard
and fast rules and the expert may not be
able to articulate those rules exactly
but we do know that the data contains
the information it needs in this case we
found that thank you that we automated
exploring the space so in the answer
might not be column a that
people to a couple columns might not be
able to tell you enough to find the
pattern or to learn and train on it but
maybe a squared is is good so we built
some transforms that you can apply to
these columns and you can do the
different things normalizing them you
can do addition or a multiplication and
a few other interesting operations that
will from one column they will get you
something more interesting and then we
automated this and the unfortunately I
couldn't show it here but what we did is
we gave the human expert a way to sort
of put some guardrails in place and say
well I'm pretty sure these are the
important columns I'm pretty sure that
viewing them in this fashion is what's
gonna get us there and then we can
explore this place the space and more
importantly once we find something
interesting in there a key point is to
be able to explain back to the human
expert what transforms were done to get
us there
[Music]
you